الرئيس الاوكراني كان من المفترض ان يلتحق
عبر الفيديو بجلسه للكونغرس الامريكي
يحاول خلالها اقناع اعضائه بالتصويت على
حزمه مساعدات جديده بقيمه 61 مليار دولار
فولوديمير زيلنسكي غاب عن الاجتماع ولم
يتطرق له خلال خطابه اليومي المعتاد مع
شعبه ممتن جدا للمدافعين عن سمائنا اليوم
تم اسقاط طائره روسيه في منطقه جزيره
زميني في البحر الاسود هذه الطائره كانت
تستهدف
اوديسا تخصيص حزمه مساعدات جديده لكيف
يثير خلافات داخليه في الكونجرس الامريكي
الجمهوريون يشترطون الموافقه عليها
بموافقه الديمقراطيين على تجديد سياسه
الهجره على الحدود مع المكسيك وهو امر
يرفضه الديمقراطيون حتى
الان اذا فشل التصويت بسبب الحدود فلن
يكون ذلك فشلا من جانب الحزبين بل فشلا
جمهوريا
لو كانوا يعتقدون ان مساله الحدود يجب ان
توضع في ميزان المساعدات لاوكرانيا فل
يقترحوا تعديلا يمكن ان يجمع 60
صوتا تطالب كياف بالمزيد من الدعم لتامين
توفير الكهرباء لسكانها خلال الشتاء
ولتجنب خساره الحرب ضد روسيا خصوصا بعد
اقرارها بتعثر هجومها المضاد الذي بدا
الصيف الماضي